the Joe Rogan experience I've read
something about that recently that
entertainment has become the primary
revenue source in Vegas whereas it used
to be gambling right but it's you know
there's there's still gambling but boy
it's hard to just convince young people
to start gambling yeah it's easy to
convince them to start dancing yep you
know yeah it's like seems normal its
natural there's well also when you're
young you don't have the money to just
risk but you have the money to go and
like experience fun yes yeah you know
like when you're older you're like okay
I can I have some of like flexible
income streams I can put down on some
blackjack what I would have loved to
seen the Sinatra days like Vegas when it
was run by the mob the Rat Pack and say
Miss Jean I just would love to been in
the room and watch watch one of those
shows and then you know come to today
and see how things have changed I mean I
think that's like the Bourdain thing
like he had been there when he was young
and then see it changed now right but I
am fascinated by change I don't resist
it and I don't I don't say all the good
old days that don't mean [ __ ] to me
I am absolutely on the same page as you
yeah I'm interested
you know I'm yeah I'm always interested
in the next thing I want to try the next
thing you know and you know you want to
enhance your experience you want to
enhance what you're doing to make it
serve you better but if you went to
someone like 1985 it said hey man guess
what 2019 electronic music [ __ ] people
go what are you talking about get this
guy out of here man there's one one guy
that did say that though who Jim
Morrison did he really yeah so like he
did a prediction it's like somewhere I'm
sure you can find it but he did a
prediction where whenever he was alive I
guess I guess probably 70 60 or 70 so he
said like the future will be one one
person with some sort of computer or
something it was that's gonna be devised
electronically or something like that
and that one person will be making music
for people and and performing that now
watch a video so remember yeah so I
I forgot what he said but he says
something to that effect and it's like
it's crazy because I was what 50 years
play this take it from the beginning
music indigenous to this country are the
black music blues and the kind of folk
music that was brought over from Europe
and when I guess they call it country
music or the kind of West Virginia a
high lonesome sound that those those are
the two main streams of route American
music there we have these others I don't
know but uh like ten years ago what they
called rock and roll was kind of a
blending of those two forms I guess in
four or five years the new generations
music will be it'll have a synthesis of
those two elements and some third thing
it'll be in town maybe it'll be it might
rely heavily on electronics tapes I can
kind of envision maybe a one person with
a lot of machines tapes and electronic
setups
singing or speaking and using machines
yes from what his mind says of what he
can consider is what that would be it's
you know he did / - he did predict yeah
I mean where it is you know like I think
that's what happens when you do acid
correctly get those sort of visions yeah
because I mean also Jim Morrison like
you could tell he's he's such an artist
that you know he could after the doors
you just be himself yeah you know he
would have done in Jim Morrison album or
he's made all the music he's done
everything he would be exactly what he's
saying he's basically predicting what he
would have in my opinion what he would
become and he was probably like 25 in
that video which is even crazier yeah
and we died at 27 that's that's crazy
nuts yeah nuts I mean that whole era of
the 1960's fascinates me to no end I
love the cars
I love the sound to this day most of the
music I listen to is classic rock I mean
I listened a lot of new stuff but man I
will pull out some [ __ ] classic rock I
love it I love listening to it yeah
there's something about it that makes me
it just makes me realize what a profound
change it was between the 1950s and
1960s that the culture exploded that
something happened something happened
and the the clothes and the music and
the sounds and the [ __ ] muscle cars
like everything went haywire like you
went from 1950 to 1960 and just a rat
[ __ ] right right there's so many great
artists you know Hendrix and yeah the
whole idea of like like okay now it's
time to experiment and to free ourselves
from the confines of what like you know
it's yes yeah right the door is wide
open
I think Buddy Holly was great I loved
Buddy Holly but if you go from Buddy
Holly to Hendrix you like what you know
that's what acid trip actually goes
right like you're say they said used to
put acid in his bandanna I don't know if
that's true yeah
that it would seep into his skin as he
was playing then he's just like lighting
his guitar on fire and picking with his
teeth man how much would you love to
watch that guy live oh yeah that was
been incredible to be in the presence of
something completely unique
you know this hippy black dude who's the
greatest guitarists of all time still
still yeah there's no one like there's
some amazing guys today Gary Clark jr.
and of course you know Stevie Ray
Vaughan was amazing there's a bunch of
great amazing guitars but also the
showmanship though you know the outfits
the like it's like all of the combined
not just his his technical ability yes
the fact that he was doing these these
things that you're like you know some of
the guitars won't wouldn't do that
that's not part of their like you know
protocol but he was just like on another
world yeah and it should be a part of
that you know see that it's incredible a
complete outlier yeah yes and again like
no one was like that before that and
like go to the 1940s it's only 20 years
yeah I mean 20 years ago
is you know we're dealing with you know
1999 that's that doesn't seem that long
ago
yeah but 69 to 49 you might as well be
from another world yeah you really might
as well be might as well be another
planet so what do you think was one of
the bigger cultural shifts of why that
happened drugs simply hundred percent
yeah 100 percent yeah I mean obviously
when we talk about Jimi Hendrix and the
Beatles and The Beach Boys like whoever
else is like yoges yeah adores Joplin
drugs yeah
drugs The Doors drugs right everyone
drugs they were there taking
mind-expanding psychedelics and the
culture had shifted to embrace these
mind-expanding psychedelics and there
was also the resistance to the Vietnam
War there's this rebellious movement
there's these young compassionate people
that were trying to figure their way
through life in a way that didn't
resonate with the way their parents had
set boundaries and standards and they
wanted out of all of it that Goldwater
Republican [ __ ] they wanted to be
free and our children and hippies and
yeah and Woodstock and all that
craziness you know yeah and what's
amazing is how quickly it ended you know
yeah so many things kiss right so many
things the deaths the death scared
people you know like you know at the
other day like when when they're
dropping at 27 yeah
you're heroes Morrison Janis Joplin
Hendrix all 27 and and like they're the
leaders of this experimental revolution
yep not good that's gonna end things
pretty quick
[Applause]